year hundreds of thousands of revelers
flocked to the destination to ring in
the new year and this year is no
exception
from breathtaking fireworks that light
up the Las Vegas guide to chart-topping
Headliners and over-the-top celebrations
no one does New Year's Eve better than
Las Vegas
America's party has become synonymous
with our New Year's Eve celebration and
is the only Vegas experience that
visitors have come to expect from the
entertainment and sports capital of the
world
we're excited to once again have
fireworks by groups you coordinate the
thrilling show launching from the eight
rooftops across iconic Las Vegas Strip
there's also an incredible lineup of
entertainment and nightlife options
available at Resorts throughout the
destination a few of those acts over New
Year's Eve weekend include pit bullet
Resorts World
Bruno Mars Adobe live at Park MGM the
killers at the Cosmopolitan of Las Vegas
Adele at Caesars Palace Gwen Stefani at
the Venetian Las Vegas and chain smokers
at Win Las Vegas
2022 was an incredible year for Las
Vegas as we continue to welcome visitors
back to the destination in fact October
set a record at Harry Reid International
Airport with over 5 million passengers
going through our International Airport
in a single month
Fisher was also
leaving a mark on the world as Las Vegas
being the sports capital of the world
and hosting the NFL draft for the first
time ever
announcing formula one will be on the
Las Vegas Strip in November 2023 and
securing the men's final four in Las
Vegas for 2028 in addition to the Super
Bowl in February 2024.
there were so many groundbreaking firsts
exciting announcements and only in Vegas
moments throughout 2022 we can't wait to
bring that energy into the new year and
Beyond thank you